Pour fêter le fait qu'on soit déjà plus de 100 000 dans la grande famille DTC
je vous avais proposé une petite FAQ :
vous m'avez envoyé énormément de questions et encore pleins de messages super sympa, merci beaucoup !
Maintenant c'est à moi de bosser, allez, c'est parti !
Question qui revient très souvent, alors on va commencer par là, comme ça ce sera fait :
Voilà !
J'ai exercé en tant qu'infirmier pendant plus de 10 ans, principalement en réanimation et au SMUR
- au SAMU, si vous préférez.
Après j'ai travaillé en libéral, c'est-à-dire que j'allais soigner les gens chez eux
et puis j'ai aussi du coaching santé, c'est-à-dire de l'éducation par téléphone.
Voilà, ça c'est pour les grandes lignes, mais j'ai aussi travaillé aux urgences, en chirurgie, en salle de réveil, au bloc opératoire, ... etc.
Alors, j'ai adoré mais j'ai arrêté parce que j'avais envie de voir autre chose, du coup je suis devenu journaliste pendant huit ans,
et puis, là, récemment j'ai encore eu envie de voir autre chose, et voilà.
J'ai commencé à faire des vidéos dans le cadre de mon métier de journaliste, que j'ai finalement quitté pour ne plus faire que ça.
Pour lancer ma chaîne Youtube, j'ai choisi la santé assez logiquement parce que c'est un sujet que je maîtrise
et que j'ai pu voir pendant les lives des Nuits originales que c'est quelque chose qui vous plaît pas mal
OUI !
UNE SAUCISSE !
Non, parce que je pense que c'est un sujet inépuisable
et en plus comme j'ai envie de traiter tous types de sujets sur la santé,
c'est encore plus inépuisable qu'un truc déjà inépuisable, donc c'est complètement inépuisable.
Mais, qui fait ça, enfin ...
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
On a travaillé ensemble chez 20 minutes, donc on s'est connu là bas,
lui, il animait une émission qui s'appelait "Le rewind", à laquelle je participais tous les jours
avec déjà l'ami Romain à la caméra, au montage et aux blagues
J'écris les vidéos et Romain s'occupe de tout le reste, c'est-à-dire la caméra, le montage, les effets spéciaux, ... etc.
Non, parce qu'il est beaucoup trop beau et j'ai pas envie qu'il me fasse de l'ombre
Ouai, bien joué Sherlock ! Ouai ouai, Romain Vitiello a bien été élu Mister Auvergne en 2014.
[Romain] : Mais tu fais quoi là ?
Bah ma ... FAQ ...
[Romain] : Non, non c'est quoi ÇA ?
Oh, ... bon, d'accord j'arrête...
[Romain] : Merci !
Pour moi tu seras toujours Mister Auvergne.
Au début, je cherchais un nom avec "santé" dedans, mais je tombais que sur des jeux de mots pourris
DTC, ça a même failli s'appeler
"Santé-moi ça"
Du coup après j'ai cherché avec le mot "corps",
et j'ai choisi "Dans Ton Corps", parce que je trouvais que "DTC" ça claquait bien,
que ça n'avait jamais été utilisé, et que ça n'évoquait absolument RIEN de graveleux.
SAUCISSE !
Je mets deux ou trois jours à écrire une vidéo de A à Z et on tourne en une demi-journée avec Romain.
Le reste du temps j'écris aussi des sketchs pour le web ou pour la télé, et à l'occasion quand on m'appelle,
bah je joue dans des sketchs, des clips, des vidéos, ...
comme dans l'excellentissime court métrage de Raphael Descraques "The Misson Square", par exemple.
Faux !
*Plaf*
Vous parlez de la vidéo sur la gueule de bois c'est ça ?
Bah non, c'est une cervelle d'agneau.
Oui bien sûr, j'en parle déjà en fait, parce que les sujets dont je parle dans DCT, ça concerne deux sexes !
Mais bon, promis, je ferais aussi des vidéos sur des sujets exclusivement féminins.
Cadeau !
Bah écoutes, je te réponds la semaine prochaine dans DTC, d'accord ?
Oui, j'ai plein de projets pour ma chaîne, j'aimerais bien avoir plusieurs formats dans lesquels je pourrais piocher en fonction du sujet
peut-être avec des invités, on verra, tout ça c'est encore un petit peu tôt, c'est tout frais ici encore.
Et en dehors de DTC, j'ai aussi bien envie de faire de la fiction, que ce soit en tant qu'auteur ou en tant que comédien.
Check tes mails, tu vas trouver.
Tu te rends pas compte que c'est super dur ce que tu me demandes, là !
Mais je dirais :
Mais c'est vraiment dur, hein !
Une sale histoire de chili beaucoup trop épicé ...
*Bruit de coulante*
Pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas, "Mon internet à moi" c'est une série d'interviews
de créateurs, vidéastes et youtubeurs que j'ai fait, et oui, j'aimerais beaucoup recommencer.
J'ai longtemps écouté QUE du métal, et puis j'ai découvert "Public Enemy" grâce à Anthrax,
et Run-DMC grâce à Aerosmith, et ... je me suis mis à aimer le rap.
Et puis après j'ai découvert plein d'autres styles musicaux,
et du moment que ça provoque un truc en moi j'écoute, je me pose plus de questions, voilà.
Mais le Metal, ça a quand même une place à part.
J'adorerais tourner avec mon frère et j'espère vraiment que ça va se faire un jour,
mais pas forcément pour raconter des dossiers d'enfance.
Bah, il fait un peu froid, heu..
Ah bah figurez-vous qu'en plus d'être extrêmement talentueux, d'avoir des goûts musicaux très sûr et d'être atrocement BG,
Waxx est terriblement gentil.
Le mec énervant, quoi.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire.
Non en vrai, je ne le remercierai jamais assez d'avoir composé juste pour moi le générique de DTC que j'adore
*Bisou*
Merci champion
Eh beh il suffit de télécharger et d'imprimer CECI et de s'en faire un masque !
Et hop ! Vous êtes Mister Auvergne.
2014.
Merci qui ? ;)
Ah ben c'est une bonne question, ça, il n'a pas de nom en fait !
Bon allez, comme on est une grande famille, on va tous choisir ensemble !
Vous allez me mettre vos propositions dans les commentaires, ok ?
Bah en fait, des insectes j'en ai déjà mangé pas mal.
*CCRROC*
Le rougail saucisse !
SAUCIIIIISSE ! 😭
Ah bonne question. Bah écoute on va voir ça tout de suite.
Quand je suis content je vomis !
Ah ouai.
Alors, je me suis fait casser le nez quatre fois, et je suis daltonien, aussi.
C'est pour ça que je m'habille tout le temps tout en noir.
Comme ça je suis sûr de ne pas merder au niveau de l'harmonie des couleurs.
Je joue au rugby. C'est pour ça que j'ai le nez de travers.
Entre autres..
J'ai fait du poney avec Tonton David.
♪ Chacun sa route, chacun son chemin ! ♫
Il y a eu aussi beaucoup de questions un peu plus personnelles, donc pour finir on va faire un instant "Livret de famille"
♪
♪♫
♪♫♪
♪♫♪♫
♪♫♪♫♪
♪♫♪♫♪♫
♪♫♪♫♪♫♪♫
C'est la jeune femme qui partage ma vie, tout simplement.
Ouais voilà, on peut rien vous cacher : la jeune femme que j'embrasse goulûment dans la vidéo, et qui partage ma vie, c'est Sophie Riche.
La fameuse Sophie Riche.
(ah ils sont forts, quand même !)
Ah..
Non. J'ai un frère génial, c'est vrai, mais c'est aucun de ceux-là. Raté.
Ah....
Alors non, je ne suis pas ADRIEN Ménielle,
je suis JULIEN Ménielle.
Et c'est normal qu'on se ressemble beaucoup parce qu'on a pas mal d'ADN en commun dans la mesure où on a les mêmes parents.
C'est mon frère en fait, c'est mon petit frère.
Mais bon si vous regardez bien, on n'a pas la même couleur de cheveux, on n'a pas la même couleur d'yeux
et on fait pas la même taille en plus.
Je suis plus grand.
Donc non, on n'est pas la même personne.
[Romain] : Et c'est bon !
Ça va elle est bonne ?
'tain ils sont forts quand même, hein ?
Parce que ...waa ! Depuis le début ils se doutent d'un truc !
Voilà, cette faq est maintenant terminée, on se retrouve mercredi prochain à 18h pour une nouvelle vidéo,
d'ici là, portez-vous bien.